no no i mean you know what's interesting  though is that that's come up um there  have been many entrepreneurs that i've  met with in local communities that have  taken on issues of entrepreneur excuse  me of the environment in very organic  ways in small ways not you're not seeing  huge movements out there but they're  definitely but i mean but that goes into  the bucket the muslim women are women  women are interested about the  communities they're interested about  building families that uh raising  families in spaces that are safe and are  uh are healthy and that includes the  environment so i wouldn't distinct be  distinctive like it's a muslim thing or  non-muslim thing